depuis quelques mois hamada traoré
collectionne les amendes pour
stationnement gênant et pour cause avec
une douzaine de places pour la maison de
quartier mendès-france les écoles
fromont et carpentier et la salle de
prière de l'association des musulmans se
garer rue guy barillot à guyancourt
relève du défi au moment des prières
c'est à chaque fois le même scénario les
voitures sans fil sur ou à côté du
trottoir là juste se transforme à moi
j'aurais bien voulu quand même que qu'on
ne dise on lui dit s'est pas
matérialisée je suis entièrement
d'accord avec eux mais au moins
faire comprendre aux gens par quelques
shows pas réussi qu'on ne peut pas se
garer la wii soit une interdiction soit
une interdiction
fin février à mada traoré a alors
demandé à la mairie de créer plus de
places lors d'un entretien avec le
responsable des associations de son côté
la ville de guyancourt refuse d'ajouter
des emplacements car un parking est
ouvert à 200 mètres de la rue et la voie
étant étroite cela poserait des
problèmes de sécurité pour les enfants
la situation est en tout cas loin d'être
réglée puisque dans quelques semaines le
local associatif va s'agrandir